aus der kategorie die dümmsten diebe der
welt stammt wohl auch dieser vorfall der
sich vergangenes wochenende im
belgischen charleroi abgespielt hat ein
geschäft für e zigaretten wollte sich
diese gruppe junger männer vor knöpfen
und dabei nicht nur waren mitgehen
lassen sondern den besitzer auch um den
inhalt seiner kasse erleichtern
geistesgegenwärtig schlug dieser ihnen
vor dafür doch lieber später noch einmal
wiederzukommen wenn die kasse auch
richtig gefüllt sei klingt logisch
dachten sich die ganoven und ließen sich
vom ladenbesitzer die die
hinauskomplimentieren der im anschluss
die ordnungshüter rief politik die die
polizei sagte mir entschuldigen sie aber
die werden sicher nicht wiederkommen
ich erwiderte doch ich denke schon denn
ich bin zwar ein guter verkäufer aber
ich glaube nicht dass sie besonders
helle sind murrend schickte die polizei
ein paar beamte vorbei die im
hinterzimmer warteten während die idee
weiter seinen geschäften nachging
dollar die diebe tauchten am abend
tatsächlich wieder auf den verkäufer
hatte seine menschenkenntnis nicht
getäuscht
fünf überraschte personen sollen
festgenommen worden sein